أعتقد أن خجل أول شيء في
الصباح ليس جيدًا ، شكرًا
لك ، إنه لمن دواعي سروري أن أكون هنا ، شكرًا
لاستضافتي ،
لا يوجد شيء من هذا القبيل ، إنه
ليس سباق خيل ، صحيح أنه
ليس كذلك ، أعني أن جون ويليامز هو
أعظم فيلم يسمى الملحن
أعني حتى وقت قريب عندما توفي أنت
تعرف صديقي ennio morricone أعني
لي أنه كان أعظم فيلم مؤلف في المتجر ،
وأنت تعلم أن لدي أيام جيدة وأيام سيئة
لدي أفلام جيدة وأفلام سيئة
يعجبني ما أضعه على هذا النحو ،
فأنا
أحب وظيفتي ، فأنا أحب
هذه
الفرصة لكوني موسيقيًا ، هذه
الفرصة لسرد القصص هذه
فرصة للعمل في الفيلم
وآمل ألا يتوقف الهاتف عن الرنين
أم
لا لا لأني أبدًا  انظر ، أنا لا أنظر
إليه أبدًا ، أعني أنه مثل
أممم ، على سبيل المثال ،
أصنع أفلامًا مثل 12 Years a Slave ،
يمكنك أن تتخيل أن هذا ليس بالضرورة
عرضًا تجاريًا للغاية ، لكنني
أعتقد أنها
قصة مهمة لأخبرك
أنني أعيشها  حياة جيدة أعيشها أنا أعيش
حياة بسيطة لأنني في معظم الأوقات أكون
في الاستوديو معظم الوقت أكون مع
موسيقيي كما تعلمون ،
فأنا لست جيدًا في الحفلات ،
فأنا لست كثيرًا.  من المتسوق ما لم يكن
يشتري أجهزة المزج ولكن
ليس الأمر حقًا لا يتعلق الأمر
بالمال
ولكنك تعلم أنه من الجيد أن
تكسب ما يكفي من المال يمكنني أن أذهب
وأقول نعم أريد أن أصنع فيلمًا لا يمكنني
الدفع  الكثير من المال ويمكننا أن نفعل
شيئًا ما ، لكنها أفكار مهمة
بالتأكيد
ويمكننا أن نفعل شيئًا يحتوي على
أفكار مهمة ،
فأنت تعرف شيئًا
سأكون صريحًا معك ،
لقد اضطررت إلى قول ما هو
فيلمك المفضل  ولا بد لي حقًا من القول إنني
أعتقد أنني قمت بعمل جيد على Interstellar ، لقد
قمت بعمل جيد في أشياء أخرى
يمكن أن تعمل على Thin Red Line وقمت بعمل جيد
في Gladiator ، لقد قمت بعمل جيد في
أشياء أخرى ولكن
يا Lion King لقد قمت بعمل جيد  العمل هو
فيلم للأطفال ولكني أعتقد أنني قمت
بعمل جيد وليس لدي مفضل وما
أعنيه هو أن أحد الأشياء
التي تدفعني هو أنني أريد أن أكتب
شيئًا حيث يمكنني أن أذهب هذا هو الشيء
وأنا  لم تفعل ذلك بعد ، كم أه
لم تفعل حتى الآن بالنسبة لـ
Interstellar Lion King ، أفهم أنه
جيد ولكنه جيد ولكن كل ما فعلته هو أنه قيل
يا احتمال
وجود الطموح وكتابة شيء
أفضل يتحدث عن Lion King إنه واحد
من أعظم أعمالك ، ما هي
العلاقة الخاصة التي
تربطك بتلك الموسيقى المليئة بالمشاعر
المليئة بالعاطفة كما تعلم ، إنها أبوة ،
أعني أن هناك جزأين
للقصة ، الجزء الأول
مضحك لم أرغب فيه.  للذهاب وعمل رسم
كاريكاتوري مع الحيوانات ، لكن ابنتي كانت تبلغ من
العمر ست سنوات وأردت اصطحابها
إلى السينما ولم أستطع الذهاب وأخذها إليك وأنت
تعرف فيلمًا عنيفًا أو
فيلمًا للكبار ، لذلك أردت فقط  التباهي
بصفتي أبًا ، لذلك اعتقدت أنه حسنًا
سأفعل ذلك ، سأقوم بعمل هذا الكارتون ، لكن
المفاجأة بالنسبة لي كانت أن هذه القصة كانت
حيوانات غامضة كانت تدور حول وفاة
والدها
والطفل الذي تركه وراءه
وتوفي والدي  عندما كنت صغيرًا جدًا ،
كنت دائمًا أكتب من
وجهة نظر شخصية أردت أن أقول
إنني كنت على صواب من القلب ، وهو ما يشبه
نوعًا من الكليشيهات ، لكن الحقيقة
هي أنني أكتب من
النجم الذي أصنع القصة قصتي و
لذلك كتبت قداسًا لوالدي
[تصفيق] ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، شكرًا
جزيلاً ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، وأتمنى أن أجيب على
أسئلتك.